yo what is up everybody Matthew here
with another Dark Souls 3 tutorial now
in this video I'm gonna show you guys
how to get the best gear that is a
necessity if you want a farm efficiently
in Dark Souls 3 you're gonna want this
gear if you're farming Souls or if
you're farming items so let's get right
into it
coming to number 1 we have the coveted
silver serpent ring this ring ups the
amount of souls you get from slaying
enemies by around 11% to find this head
up to the ceiling of Firelink shrine via
the tree or the lock tower and make your
way to the far side of the ceiling
there's going to be an illusionary wall
there hit it and there should be a chest
nearby I think you have to drop down
open a chest and there you go the
covetous silver serpent ring next up we
have the covetous gold serpent ring this
ring increases item discovery by 50
extremely helpful if you're firing for
specific items this one can be found in
the toxic area in the profaned capital
you don't want to jump off a blue
shingled roof to an open window walk-up
and there should be a cell to open up
that has the ring inside of it and
possibly sick bird of catarina if you're
doing this quest line he might be here
too coming into third we have the shield
of wand this shield ups the amount of
souls drop by enemies by 20% and is
stackable with other soul increasing
items such as the silver serpent ring to
find it head to smoldering lake and head
to where the giant worm is located there
should be a couple corpses on the ground
with items on them and the shield should
be among them at number four we have
probably the strongest farming item in
the game regardless of what playthrough
you're on the symbol of avarice or the
mimics head
this increases soul absorption by 50%
and item discovery by 99 now that's more
than everything else combined however
these benefits do come at the price of
draining your health this symbol has a
chance to drop from any mimic in the
game however it's a somewhat low chance
or if you kill every single mimic than
the last one you kill will give you the
symbol of avarice so you have to kill
every mimic in a playthrough if you want
this for sure or you can follow my
strategy for dropping it from any normal
mimic strategy I'm talking about is to
go up to the mimic punch it and then hit
it with a lloyd salesman to put it to
sleep loot it it should give you its
normal item and repeat this punching it
and putting it to sleep and it should
give you the simple average get lucky or
it'll drain empty then you can kill it
and you might get the symbol it doesn't
work go find another mimic and keep
doing this I found this the first time I
implemented this strategy on a mimic an
early movement is in the tower under the
dragon at the high wall of law 3 and
finally we have a couple more items that
will help this not as significant as the
other things but we have the coins the
rusted coin and the rusted gold coin up
item discovery by 50 and 100
respectively if you get patches as a
vendor and firely trying he sells
I think infinite rusted coins for 200
souls of pop he doesn't sell infinite he
sells like 200 or so which is a lot and
that's going to be per playthrough so
that's basically infinite and the rusty
gold coins appear to be a limited
resource found throughout the world so
you have to go throughout the world and
you can find them they are basically
double the rusted coin and these coins
do not stack upon themselves so you can
use a rusted coin and a rusted gold coin
and they'll stack but you can't use two
rusted coins it'll give you the same as
using one so hope you guys have enjoyed
this video this quick little tutorial on
how to get the best gear for farming if
you're going to be farming for a lot of
items or a lot of souls or gonna be
farming for a long time you're really
going to want this gear since this gear
will make it go by a lot faster
appreciate you guys watching the video
check out my channel if you want more
Dark Souls content I have a lot of stuff
up and I'll be continuing to post a lot
of stuff thank you for watching
peace out